Das Podcast, unbekanntes Flugobjekt, inzwischen mehr als ein unbenanntes Schulprojekt, auf Platz elf in den Spotify-Podcast-Charts, knapp die Top Ten verpasst um die Breite eines Fotzenhaars. Fanta T und Teenie W mit Gags in dein Gesicht, es ist ein relativ guter Podcast, aber mehr auch nicht.
Podcast UFO. Glaube ich. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich zeitgeistig bin. Zeitgeistig, bei uns natürlich heute im Studio, Drehbuchautor, Satiriker, Comedian, Lebemann, wie das alles zusammenpasst, soll er uns selber erklären. Er ist heute Abend hier, Stefan Tietze. Hallo, Dankeschön. Und Flo und Dennis auch da. Dankeschön, ja. Stupid, vielen Dank für das fantastische Intro. Klingt so moderne Musik, Herr Will? Ich glaube, ja, das ist eines der vier Eckpfeiler der Hip-Hop-Kultur, das sind nämlich Graffiti, Sprechgesang, also ich dachte, Dactylus, Anapes, Trocheus, Anapes und Jambos, und Jambos. Und Sprechgesang, Graffiti, Breakdance und das Vierte vergesse ich immer. An Wort Graffiti, also es ist ein guter Test immer, um herauszufinden, ob der die gegenüber sich mit der Materie auskennt, Streetcred hat. Weil ich finde, das ist ein bisschen wie Tattoo. Leute, die Tattoo sagen, die haben wahrscheinlich kein Tattoo. Und Leute, die Graffiti sagen, haben wahrscheinlich auch noch nie ein Graffiti-Hauswand getaggt. Ist aber eins der Worte, das ich auch eher wegnuschle, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich eher umgehe, wenn dann eher umgehe und wenn ich es unbedingt sagen muss, man kommt ja manchmal in die Situation, wo man unbedingt um das Wort Graffiti nicht mehr rumkommt. Ja, wie ich neulich, wo ich dich in der Ecke gedrängt habe, in so einer dunklen Gasse. Sags! Sags! Du hast mich geschubst links, rechts, als ich weglaufen wollte, hast du mich abgepackt. Und dann habe ich gesagt, Graffiti, ha ha ha, Graffiti, ha ha, Graffiti. Das ist eigentlich ein italienisches Wort, Graffiti, so wie Paparazzi. Toll. Ich habe auch manchmal so Wörter, die kenne ich nur geschrieben und es wird auch, glaube ich, immer schlimmer, so im Internetzeitalter. Ja, es ist schon schwierig. Ich weiss noch, wie wir damals vor langer, langer Zeit am Bahnhof standen, um in die USA zu fliegen und wir am Flughafen ein älteres Pärchen überhört haben, das sich unterhalten hat, über den Präsidenten Trump.
Wo wir auch sehr erstaunt waren, wie man den Namen vielleicht noch nie gehört hat.
Das ist nur gelesen.
Oder wo man einfach drauf beharrt und sagt, nee, ich nenne das so, ich spreche das deutsch aus.
Wie man ja auch Parmesan sagt und nicht Parmigiano, sagt man ja auch Trump statt Trump. Ja, wobei, genau, ich glaube, es ist auch eher so eine Beharrlichkeit, der kommt ja aus Deutschland, die Vorfahren kommen ja aus Deutschland. Wenn er nicht so wie er wahrscheinlich hieß, Trump, als ein, ich habe den Namen noch nie gehört, richtig, ich weiß nicht, wie man es aussprechen soll. Aber wo du gerade bei italienischen Namen warst, ist es interessant, dass man als Deutschland entschieden hat, eigentlich in allen Ländern die Städte zu nennen, wie sie dort genannt werden, außer in Italien. Überall, also in England nennen wir jede Stadt eigentlich so, wie sie heißt. Brighton, London, was auch immer. In Spanien auch, Madrid, Sevilla, Barcelona, was auch immer. Aber du hast es alle schon gesagt. Ich habe es alle gesagt, die es gibt. Aber in Italien sagen wir Mailand statt Milano, wir sagen Rom statt Roma, wir sagen Neapel statt Napoli, wir sagen Sardinien statt, ne, Also wir sagen quasi Palermo. Ich war noch nie, aber ja, das kann gut sein, aber ja, ist interessant. Warum ausgerechnet, hat das Dritte Reich Gründe? Weiß ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt, ob wir uns da hinwagen wollen. Vielleicht auch römische Gründe, ich weiß nicht. Ich habe jetzt Barbaren angeschaut auf Netflix, habe ich mir schön reingezogen, wo die alle Latein sprechen. Ich auch, aber nur die Stellen, wo sie Latein gesprochen haben, weil ich die klassisch finde. Und ich war ein bisschen erstaunt, dass es einfach klingt wie Italienisch. Ja. Es klingt einfach wie Italienisch. Also ich kann Italienisch nicht gut genug, um den Unterschied zu erkennen, von daher klang es für mich einfach wie Plissens Italienisch. Ja, ein paar von den Schauspielern waren auch Italiener, glaube ich, die das dann auch relativ gut aussprechen konnten. Und ich habe in meiner Sprachbubble dann auch viele Videos gesehen, ob das korrektes Latein ist und nicht und so. Aber ich habe es da nicht ganz angeguckt. Also weißt du auch die Antwort nicht. Ich weiß die Antwort nicht. Ich klicke immer gern drauf und damit denke ich, habe ich meinen Bildungsauftrag eigentlich schon erfüllt. Und dann läuft es halt so nebenbei und ich sage mir, boah, bin ich klug, ich schaue das an, das Video. Ich bin schon echt ein aufgeschlossener, weltoffener Typ. Da gucke ich mir ein Video an über Latein und kriege nichts von dem Video mit, das läuft durch in dreifache Geschwindigkeit, aber währenddessen denkst du... Das ist doch die Werbung, du kriegst schon weg. Aber das gilt mir genauso. Ich habe auch jetzt neulich zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben den Film Primer gesehen. Kennst du den? Das ist dieser abgekultete Zeitreisefilm von Hayden Christensen, oder? Nee, Jumper, Looper. Du meinst einen ganz anderen Film. Mungie. Sowohl Jumper und Looper sind ähnliche Filme, aber die sind nicht Teil des Films, von dem ich sprechen möchte. Jumper, Looper und Primer sind drei unterschiedliche Filme, die nichts miteinander zu tun haben. Wobei zwei von denen gehen im Zeitreisen, aber das ist jetzt auch der kleinste Gemeinsamende. Primer ist einer der komplizisten Filme, sagt man so, der fiel auch oft, wenn es um Tenet ging, in dieser ganzen Diskussion über hochkomplexe, zu komplexe, überkomplexe Filme, fiel auch oft Primer. Kann man kostenlos gucken bei Prime Video, was ironisch, aber ihr könnt Primer bei Prime gucken, Primer Video und könnt da den Film gucken, macht das mal. Und dann kann man nämlich zu YouTube gehen, und dann muss man noch mit einem berechnen in die 90 Minuten Guckzeit, dass danach noch 23 Minuten für ein Video draufgehen, was einem den Film erklärt. Jetzt braucht man dafür aber mehr als 23 Minuten, weil man das immer wieder pausieren muss, um darüber nachzudenken. Und das war, glaube ich, das einzige Video, was ich jemals ganz geguckt habe. Für 23 Minuten ist aber nicht schlecht. Das habe ich durchgehalten, weil ich gedacht habe, wie kann man denn so bescheuert seinen Film nicht verstehen. Dieses Video hat aber dazu geführt, dass ich, ich habe es immer noch nicht verstanden im Film, aber ich bin damit im Reinen. Weil das Video, ein 23-Minuten-Video, was mir nicht die Story erklärt, sondern nur diese Zeitreisen-Kontroversen, Komplexe, da habe ich mir schon gedacht, okay, darin liegt ja schon versteckt, dass der Film nicht verstanden werden will so richtig und wenn es so ein Video braucht, dann ist es schon okay, dass man den nicht versteht. Fantastischer Film, macht unfassbar viel Spaß, schau dir mal, Primer, reden wir nächste Woche drüber. Macht aber vor allem Spaß nach den 23 Minuten, wo man nochmal sagt so, yeah, oh mein Gott, deswegen, der Twist, jetzt habe ich ihn verstanden. Ach, die waren befreundet. Ah ja, richtig gut, aber finde ich auch gut. Und ich fand ja auch diesen Post so toll mit Robert Pattinson, der meinte, er hat den Grossteil der Dreharbeiten von Tenet den Film nicht verstanden, was ich mir so gut vorstellen kann. Ich glaube, das ist ja oft so, wenn man Szenen nicht chronologisch dreht und dann denkt, okay, ich habe jetzt eine Charakterwaltung durchgemacht von mir aus, aber ich finde das so gut, dass sie einfach nach Hause gehen und dann fragt die Frau, und was hast du gedreht heute? Du, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, keine Ahnung. Und der ist ja die Figur, die alles... Aber der Schuss ging in, aber der Schuss ging in meine Pisklare rein. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Genau, ich habe geschossen und dann hat die Kugel mich getroffen. Aber dann ist nicht Blut aus mir gekommen, sondern ich habe Blut dann getrunken. Das Blut hat mich, ich bin aus der Wunde rausgefallen. Und dann kommt ja noch der technische Aspekt hinzu, der nämlich ist, er hat alles richtig rumgemacht. Nee, er musste ja bluten. Er musste ja rückwärts laufen. Oh Gott, oh Gott. Und warum nochmal muss er rückwärts laufen? Naja, das ist ja umgekehrt gerade. Aber es ist noch komplizierter ein bisschen, es ist noch eins komplizierter, weil er musste ja alles, auch diese Inverted Scenes, musste er ja richtig rum aufnehmen. Das heißt, du hast noch eine Schleife mehr im Kopf eigentlich, weil er musste ja bluten. Wste also nicht, dass das rückwärts abgespielt wird, damit es dann zu der Szene grob passt. Einfach keine Ahnung, aber apropos schneller abspielen, möchte ich gerne deine Meinung dazu fragen. Netflix, man kann jetzt Sachen mit doppelter Geschwindigkeit abspielen. Kann man jetzt? Ja. Hast du das schon gemacht? Ich habe es schon einmal gemacht, dachte mir aber so, nee, das kannst du nicht nee, das kannst du nicht machen. Da hat Stefan Tietze jahrelang hart daran gearbeitet, geschrieben, gedreht. Das kannst du jetzt nicht in doppelter Geschwindigkeit wegsaugen eigentlich, das geht nicht. Würdest du dich beleidigt fühlen, wenn jemand zu dir sagt, ich habe deine Serie geguckt, also ich habe es ja auf doppelter Geschwindigkeit geguckt, aber ich habe sie gesehen. Also bei der Serie bin ich mal gespannt, ob das jemand in doppelter Geschwindigkeit gucken kann. Weil jetzt wird eh die ganze Zeit geredet, während geschrieben wird, während über jemanden, der redet, geschrieben wird. Ja. Also, und dann wird eh schon sehr viel geschnitten. Ich glaube nicht, dass das Sinn macht, unsere Serie auch in doppelter Geschwindigkeit zu. Im Gegensatz zu anderen Serien, wo ja kaum geschnitten wird, wo die teilweise aus dem Raum gehen und immer noch gefilmt wird, obwohl niemand mehr im Raum ist. Wir haben doppelt so viele Schnitte als das Parfüm, das Parfüm. Parfüm ist auch so ein Wort. Das ist, da kannst du dir wirklich was an die Wand hängen, so einfach, nimm das Parfüm, nimm das fucking Parfüm. Ja, aber die haben 60 Minuten und wir haben doppelt so viele Schnitte in unserer 30-Minuten-Serie als die in einem stundendigen Format. Wir haben sehr viele Schnitte. Wir schneiden. Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Und deswegen, glaube ich, sollte man unsere Serie nicht gucken.
Das Parfum hingegen wird dann
automatisch zu How to Sell Drugs.
How to Sell Parfum Online Fast.
Eigentlich auch eine gute Möglichkeit.
Parfümfälscher. Ich habe ja
letztens diese Doku gesehen
über diesen Weinfälscher, seitdem denke ich mir immer,
was könnte alles gefälscht sein in
meiner Umgebung. Ich traue nichts mehr und denke mir so, vielleicht ist das alles gefälscht, vielleicht ist das gar nicht das Richtige. Immer wenn ich mir irgendein technisches Produkt kaufe, denke ich mir, könnte es eine Fälschung sein, vielleicht ist die Hälfte gefälscht. Irgendwann kommt das ja raus dann. Manchmal denke ich mir, aber ist es denn so schlimm, wenn was gefälscht ist, weil die, oft zahlt man ja wirklich einfach nur für Namen. Und wenn etwas gefälscht ist, ist ja vielleicht sogar, vielleicht sogar mehr Arbeit reingeflossen in das Produkt als bei dem anderen Produkt, wo du einfach so lieblos hingerotzt vom Fließband was bekommst. Diese Fälscherfirma musste ja erstmal sich das genau abgucken oder hat vielleicht sogar komplizierter gefälsscht oder ist die Idee von Fälschen das schnelle Geld
und man versucht weniger Material, ja schon
Materialkosten zu sparen. Ich musste letztens Kerzen
kaufen, Kerzen bestellt,
die waren komplett
komplett gefälscht,
das war einfach so ein bisschen Wolle zusammengedrückt
mit einer Schnur drin, das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Ich bin auch schon drauf reingefallen.
Dann gab es aber auch so Kerzen, die aussehen wie eine Banane
oder so, wo ich mir auch dachte, eigentlich würde ich gerne in einer Wohnung leben, wo nichts das ist, wie es aussieht. Wo ich irgendwie, ich habe Das ist ein Schiff, das ist ein Schiff, das ist ein Schiff, das ist ein Schiff, das ist ein Schiff, das ist alles anders aussieht, wo die Banane ist, das Telefon und dann habe ich irgendwie so ein Waffeleisen, das eigentlich Kuchen ist oder so.
Das finde ich ein mega Konzept, weil es gibt ja diesen Sessel, der ein Baseballhandschuh ist.
Genau, sowas.
Alles ist da, aber in der Form von etwas anderem.
Ja, genau. Und du rechnest nicht, was es ist. Ach, du spielst Tennis? Nee, es ist eine Kerze.
Einfach so ein Tennisschläger als Kerze.
Das ist wahnsinnig verwirrt, glaube ich.
Überall andere Sachen und dann so, zünde mal die Kerze an und du gehst zum Feuerzeug so und dann
weißt du nicht, was es ist und dir gießt
keine Kerze und dann hast du
eine schöne Atmosphäre. Bei mir ist nämlich das Licht kaputt gegangen
und ich bin so ein Einlösungstyp.
Wenn ich überhaupt eine Lösung habe, dann eine.
Also Lampe geht aus und ich denke
mir, ha ha ha, keine
Chance, ich weiß, was man machen muss,
Glühbirne wechseln,
voll selbstbewusst mit stolz geschwellter Brust schreit ich zum Schrank Ich bin ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, einühbirne wechseln. Völl selbstbewusst, mit
stolz geschwellter Brust,
schreit ich zum Schrank,
hau den Schrank auf,
hau die Klappe fast aus den Angeln,
denk mir, ich bin vorbereitet,
ich greif da oben rum,
hol mir schöne neue Glühbirne,
lauf erst mal schön mit
cooler Musik zurück in mein Wohnzimmer,
schraub die Glühbirne rein, mach an, immer noch kaputt. Und das war's. Dann ist Ende. Und jetzt habe ich einfach keine Lampe mehr in meinem Wohnzimmer. Und ich weiß nicht, was jetzt noch der andere ist. Du bist kein Rätselfan. Ich bin ein Rätselfan. Ich bin ein Rätselfan, solange ich die Lösung kenne. Und wenn die nicht funktioniert, dann gibt die auch. Also bist du kein Rätselfan. Ja doch, ich mag das schon. Du bist Lösungsfan. Ich bin Lösungsfan, ja. Ich bin komplett Lösungsfan. Ich mag die Fragen, du magst die Antworten. Genau, eigentlich würden wir sehr gut zusammenpassen, vielleicht sollten wir einen Podcast starten. Jedenfalls habe ich dann immer das Bedürfnis, herauszufinden, so, das ist ja kein schwieriges Rätsel, wenn die Glühbirne, entweder was bei dir sehr gut sein kann, du hast eine kaputte Glühbirne
in deinen Schrank gepackt.
Kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, also no offense,
aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass eine Glühbirne
kaputt ist und du jetzt nicht überlegst,
wie, also du erstmal dieses
Problem hast und du magst keine Probleme,
wie entsorge ich Glühbirnen, sollen wir dann nicht
wegwerfen? Ja, das ist so das Kirschkernproblem,
wenn du eine Schüssel Kirschen hast und dann
isst du eine Kirsche und dann tust du den Kern wieder in die Schüssel. Und dann weißt du nicht, ab jetzt, was du greifst, ist es eine Kirsche oder ein Kern. Du bist völlig aufgeschmissen. Genau, und so ist es mit den Glühbirnen auch. Du schraubst sie raus und wirfst sie in die Kiste, in die pfirsichförmige Kiste, wo die anderen Glühbirnen drin sind. Wo die anderen bananförmigen Glühbirnen drin sind. Birnenförmigen Glühbirnen. Guck mal, das ist doch ein Gag, oder? Eine Glühbirne, die die Form einer Birne hat. Oder das ist doch ein Gag, wenn du sagst, kannst du kurz das Licht anmachen und du, ja klar, du machst den Schalter an und die Birnen im Obstkorb gehen alle an. Das wäre für mich eine Wohnung, wo ich gerne nach Hause kommen würde.
Das wäre wirklich eine gute Wohnung, aber auch eine sehr verwirrende Wohnung. Ich glaube, tagsüber geht es, wenn man sich daran gewöhnt und alles sieht, aber wenn man dann so nachts, kennt man ja, wenn man nachts mal raus muss, nervt diese Art Wohnung, glaube ich. Wenn man in der Dunkelheit sich Dinge ertastet und alles ist erst mal falsch. Ja, ich habe auch mal so eine Doku gesehen über so einen Online-Versand für Sextoys und die wollten das halt so komplett neu aufziehen, so ja, das ist nichts perverses, das ist ganz normal und wir machen das so total cool, trennen die irgendwie nicht so unter der Ladentheke, sondern so mit Stolz und deren Konzept war, dass die Sextoys aber aussehen wie was anderes. Also, dass du die normal deine Wohnung stellst, was eigentlich der Firmenidee völlig widerspricht, aber dass du die normal in deine Wohnung stellen kannst und niemand weiss, dass es ein Sextoy ist. Und dann hatte die dann so irgendwie so ein Vibrator, der aussah. Ja, das ist das Gegenteil von der Idee. Die Ideologie ist, wir gehen offen damit um, nicht mehr versteckend, weil es aussieht wie eine Banane, das ist doch Quatsch. Ja, aber du kannst es dir ja kaufen, ohne dass du weisst, dass es ein Sextys ist. Also da war dann irgendwie so ein Vibrator, der aussah wie so ein Apfel und der lag halt dann einfach, stand dann normal wie ein Apfel rum und sie meinte dann so, niemand weiß unser schmutziges Geheimnis und da habe ich mir auch gedacht, so irgendwann hast du eine komplette Wohnung eingerichtet, die einfach komplett aus Sextoys besteht und wenn irgendwann mal irgendwie der einen Schalter angeht und die gesamte Wohnung vibriert einfach und alles dreht durch, dann hast du ein Problem.
Aber das fand ich eine gute Idee. Das ist die allerlösste Geschichte, die ich seit langem gehört habe, hat mir eine Freundin erzählt, die Besuch hatte von ihren Eltern und ihren Neffen. Interessante Kombination. Ja, und auch Geschwister und Neffen. Die ganze Familie war da, versammelt in der Wohnung. Und der kleinste Neffe hatte dann so eine, er möchte Doktor sein, Rollenspielphase. Und hat dann gesagt, er wollte dann jeden sprechen im Sprechzimmer. Er wollte halt Arzt spielen und ist dann halt ins Schlafzimmer gegangen und hat dann jeden zu sich reingebeten. Und die besagte Freundin, der diese Wohnung gehört, war die Letzte in der Kette. Also alle mussten schon rein und alle mussten sich irgendwelche Krankheiten ausdecken, weswegen sie zum Arzt kommen. Und dann geht sie rein und legt sie auch dann hin, hat sich dann irgendwie einen Beinbruch ausgesagt oder sowas und spürt plötzlich halt das Stethoskop, also das, was das Kind als Stethoskop benutzt, die ganze Zeit an ihrem Bein und guckt dann so hoch. Und dann hatte der Neffe halt den Vibrator in der Hand und als Untersuchungsobjekt benutzt. Das Problem ist jetzt aber, dass sie halt die Letzte war. Sie hat es ihm dann weggenommen und gesagt, du kannst damit nicht spielen. Aber es war die letzte in der Kette. Vater war schon im Untersuchungsraum, die Mutter, die Schwester, alle waren schon im Untersuchungsraum. Sie kam dann rein und das ist dann schon unangenehm, glaube ich, wenn man dann so zurückkommt ins Wohnzimmer und dann fertig ist mit der Untersuchung, das Kind weint, weil man dem das Spielzeug weggenommen hat. Aber es war einer dieser neuen Vibratoren, die aussehen wie ein Stethoskop oder noch klassisches Design oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Es ist noch klassisches Design. Aber das war nicht so schlecht. Aber wie ist der da rangekommen? Hat der das einfach instinktiv gefunktet? Sieht halt lustig aus wie ein Raumschlupf, glaube ich. Ja. Ich glaube, es ist schon, ich glaube, als Kind greift man zu solchen Formen. Ich glaube, wahrscheinlich lag es einfach neben dem Bett, weil die Freundin nicht dachte, dass doch jemand da abends ist, reingeht, wenn die Familie dann da ist. Aber gut, eine sehr unangenehme Geschichte, aber könnte so bei Jerks laufen oder sowas, dachte ich. Das wäre ein, also Jerks. Das sind immer die schönsten Situationen so in dieser Fantasiewelt von Kindern. Ich habe das ja zivil gemacht mit Kindern und da war auch ständig, kommt dann die kleine Julia an und sagt, ich lade dich ein zum Kuchen essen und dann setzt sie dich da hin und dann sitzen da die Bären da am Tisch und du aha, jetzt wer will Tee und dann macht sie den Ofen auf, alles keine echten Sachen da, sie tut dann so, holt den Kuchen aus dem Ofen und sagt dann, oh nein, der Kuchen ist verbrannt. Und ich so, wirklich? Der sieht gar nicht so verbrannt aus.
Doch, der ist verbrannt.
Ja, aber Kinder checken die Yes-And-Improv-Regel. Und du sitzt da und sagst, nein. Ja, nicht mal, nein. Und dann haut sie den Kuchen weg und sagt, jetzt muss ich einen neuen Kuchen backen. Ich so, na, schwierig. Dann packt sie einen neuen Kuchen, dauert auch nicht lange auf, dann serviert sie den Kuchen, nimmt sich ein Stück und sagt, nee, der schmeckt furchtbar, schmeißt den Kuchen wieder weg und ich so, nee, der muss nicht furchtbar schmecken. Dein Mind ist endless. Aber ihr Mind war wirklich endless, sie hat unendlich viele Situationen kreiert, die irgendwie dieses Kuchenessen ruinieren. Sie hat dann irgendwie ah, da ist was drin, da ist was Falsches drin. Weil sie wollte, dass du da bleibst. Kann auch sein. Sie wollte nicht, dass das Essen endet, das Essen. Ja, kann auch sein. Weil ich hatte es eilig. Ich musste weg so. Ich musste mich nur an alle anderen kümmern. Du musst aber mit dem einen Bären muss es nur noch los. Aber es ist halt schwer, Smalltalk zu führen mit so zwei ausgestopften Plüschtieren, während sie in der Küche ist und den Kuchen backt und du dann neben so einem Eisbären sitzt und einem anderen Bären und dann, da sagt man, seid ihr verwandt, ist das irgendwie respektlos, wenn man das fragt, seid ihr zusammen angereist, nee, warum, ich frag nur. Ich habe gerade das Problem, dass ich auch nicht so richtig weiter weiß, weil ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber man hat schon so ein bisschen das Bedürfnis ja auch schlagfertig und cool im Alltag zu reagieren. Man denkt ja auch, man macht ja im weitesten Sinne auch was mit Humor, man muss ja auch irgendwie cool reagieren können und so. Manchmal macht einem da irgendwie die Realität so ein bisschen richtig die Rechnung, weil also ich habe jetzt einen neuen Kiosk, wo ich immer hingehe, um meine Pakete abzugeben, das ist auch so ein Paketshop, mein DHL-Paketshop. Also wenn ich Pakete bekomme und die wir jetzt rückschicke, gehe ich da hin oder aber da werden direkt hingeliefert. Das hängt bei mir um die Ecke und dann gehe ich da hin und die hat immer so sehr sperrige, die versucht immer lustig zu sein. Die Frau da, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem, was du auch mit deinem Mate-Guy hast. Es ist schwierig, pass auf, also die versucht immer lustig zu sein einigermaßen, aber die Prämissen, die sie dafür verwendet, sind sehr, sehr sperrig. Ich gehe da hin und hatte ein sehr längliches Paket und sie hat dann gesagt, ich habe den ganzen Tag schon Sonnenhunger. Was ist da wohl drin, eine grosse Spaghetti? Und ich dachte mir, was sagt man denn darauf jetzt? Und meine Antwort war, nein. Klassisches No-End. Ja, aber wo ich dann auch dachte, was denkt sie jetzt, was da drin ist? Wenn sie den Gag macht, was ist da drin, ich habe schon Hunger, stell mir vor, da, da ist eine große Spaghetti drin und ich sage, nein, bringt das ja irgendwie mit sich, dass da etwas seltsameres drin ist als eine große Spaghetti. Ja, weil du hast noch mal drei Ecken weiter gedacht als sie, weil ich sage, nein, nein, weil ich das so unangenehm gesagt habe, denke ich mir, sie müsste jetzt ja wahrscheinlich denken, ah fuck, jetzt habe ich dir unangenehm was angesprochen, was hat er denn wohl in seinem
länglichen Paket?
Oder sie denkt, ich habe einfach gar keinen Humor
und sage, nein,
sowas gibt es ja gar nicht.
Sowas wie ein länglicher Spaghetti.
Ich finde es aber auch gut, dass du einfach einfrierst
und vier Minuten lang nachdenkst,
angeschränkt und dann sagst,
nein, sehr
kleiner Baumstamm. Ja gut, das macht dann 93. Ja. Ich nehme noch zwei von den Gummikola-Plassen. Das zweite Mal, als ich da war, wurde es noch ein bisschen schlimmer. Also nicht schlimmer, aber dann bin ich wirklich so eingefroren, weil dann dachte ich mir, jetzt darf mir sowas nicht normal passieren. Und das war wirklich ein Tag drauf oder sowas, und dann bin ich da hingegangen und habe ein sehr großes Paket abgegeben und dann hat sie das genommen und gesagt, ach, das ist ganz leicht. Grosse Pakete sind immer leicht und kleine Pakete sind immer gross. Das stimmt. Und ich habe gesagt, aber dann, erstens finde ich nicht. Na doch. Nein! Und es war auch so ein bisschen sprechlich, weil es war auch nicht so leicht. Es war verhältnismäßig leicht für die Größese des Pakets. Und es ist sehr stark. Ja, aber das war auch wieder so eine Situation. Hatte mich mit grossen Augen angeguckt, hat eine Reaktion erwartet. Und von mir kam auch wieder nichts, weil auch das fand ich wahnsinnig sperrig. Ja, da kann man schwer drauf aufbauen, das ist wirklich schwierig. Ja, beide Sachen. Sowohl ist da drin eine grosse Spaghetti, nein, als auch grosse Pakete sind immer leicht, kleine sind immer gross. Und dann guckt es mich immer an, so erwartungsvoll, und von mir kommt halt gar nichts. Wo ich mir auch denke, vielleicht muss ich auch einfach aufhören mit diesem Podcast. Ich bin offensichtlich nicht in der Lage, aus sperrigen Prämissen was zu machen. Aber ich finde es gut, wenn du da auch immer dich vorbereitest und wirklich so fünf Comebacks in der Hand hast und dann kommt was
komplett anderes. Aber das ist ja schon durchaus
kreativ und ich finde die Beobachtung,
große Kisten sind klein,
finde ich hervorragend, weil das ist genau meine
Erfahrung.
Beim Umzug immer die grössten Kisten greifen,
weil da sind dann Kissen drin
oder Bettwäsche oder so ein Kram
und dann irgendwie so die Bleifiguren
Sammlung oder sowas, das ist dann immer in der kleinen Box, die dann wahnsinnig schwer ist. Ja, ich war da anderem. Also mein Kopf hat zu lang gebraucht, um da auch mit einem coolen Comeback zu kommen. Deswegen habe ich auch einfach nur gesagt, ja. Und jetzt bin ich der, ich antworte lächelnd mit Ja, nein, Guy. Aber du hast recht, das nächste Paket, was ich abge abgebe, das gucke ich mir vorher genau an, von allen Seiten.
Oder du kommst wirklich mit einem Paket, das keine Eigenschaften hat. Ja, das denke ich mir auch. Wo wirklich so, wie sieht ein Paket aus, zu dem man nicht... Das ist das normalste Paket. Das finde ich geil, dass du sie herausforderst. Und dass du wirklich, oder dass du vielleicht einmal kommst mit so einem wirklich winzigen Paket, so ein Zentimeter, war ein Zentimeter. Und ich habe mir alles überlegt. Das ist so unglaublich schwer. Nur um zu gucken, welcher Gag von ihr kommt und dann irgendwie so ein Paket, das so aussieht wie ein Pferd. Das wirklich genau aussieht wie ein Pferd. Oh, was ist denn da drin? Eine Giraffe? Und ich sage, fuck, das war mein Gag. Aber das ist eigentlich ganz geil. Okay, du hast mir damals eine Hausaufgabe gegeben. Jetzt gebe ich dir auch eine Hausaufgabe. Doch, überleg dir drei unkonventionelle Pakete, gib die ab und registriere, was sie als Kommentar darauf sagt.
Einmal so wirklich vielleicht so ein Ring, so wirklich einen schönen Ring, dann einmal das Pferd, so ein Pferdpaket und dann einmal so ein winzig kleines, das wirklich so gross ist wie eine Würfel, wo dann so auch ganz winzig deine Adresse. Finde ich spannend. Wie gross ist das kleinste Paket, was man verschicken kann? Ja, sehr gut. Ich glaube nämlich nicht, dass es so viel kleiner geht als ein Brief. Aber probier es doch einfach mal. Aber irgendwann kannst du ja einen Brief verschicken mit diesem kleinen Inhalt drin. Aber probierst du doch so ein kleines Paket, wo auch so ganz, ganz winzige von diesen weissen Schaumstoffwürmern drin sind. Da sind so ganz, ganz winzige drin und dann für so ein Stück. Aber könnte ich jetzt sozusagen so eine Sendmünze, könnte ich die verpacken mit so diesem braunen Papier und da dann diesen großen DHL-Sticker draufkleben? Ja, klar. Würde es dann verschickt werden? Ja, klar, die schnippt das dann in die grosse Box, ich weiß es nicht, aber bestimmt. Da fällt dir bestimmt ein bissiger, sehr sperriger Kommentar zu ein, auf den ich eine Antwort habe. Ja, das macht mich ein bisschen wahnsinnig, weil ich weiß nicht genau, ob ich darauf reagieren soll. Und ich habe das Gefühl, sie fischt auch so in meinem beruflichen Metier, wo ich eigentlich mich zu Hause fühlen sollte. Aber mit ihr habe ich bislang noch keine... Du bist privat unterwegs. Das kann man nicht von dir erwarten, du bist da privat unterwegs. Eigentlich müsstest du reagieren mit Entschuldigen Sie, ich bin hier privat, ich bin gerade nicht im Dienst, ich bin hier in Zivil, ich habe meine rote Nase nicht auf und abseits davon möchte ich damit auch nichts zu tun haben. Meine Podcast-Uniform abgelegt. Genau, ja, ist mein Beruf, aber ich bin heute Privatmensch. Ich bin heute einfach nur Mensch. Ich bin heute Stefan Tietze der Mensch. Lachen Sie nicht, ich bin privat hier. Ja. Bitte lachen Sie nicht. Ist auch wichtig, das zu trennen. Ist auch wichtig, das zu trennen. Aber ich bin da, ich habe zum ersten Mal habe ich dich verstanden, weil man will nicht, dass man die ganze Zeit, kann ich einfach alles normal sein? Ja. Ich möchte nicht angesprochen werden auf mein Paket, auf die Weirdness meines Pakets. Nee, ich auch. Ich hatte ja ein Riesenproblem jetzt auch mit dem Leckermate-Typen, weil ich jetzt noch eine Schippe oben drauf gelegt habe, weil ich ja in der Vorweihnachtszeit wollte ich die Clubmate Winteredition suchen. Und die gibt es manchmal bei manchen Kiosken und manchmal nicht. Das heißt, ich muss wohl wieder durch und muss halt das absuchen. Und dann ist halt dieser Laden halt meistens leer. Und dann habe ich immer schon geguckt, ist da noch jemand drin, damit ich an der Cover da reingehen kann? Nein, geh rein, such danach, schau halt wirklich so kurz, wie es nur geht, in die Mate-Abteilung, scan das alles ab, ob die Winter-Edition dabei ist, sehe ich schon den Typen wieder hervorkommen als, ah, ganz schön grosse Auswahl, oder? Oh mein Gott. Und ich kann schlecht sagen, nee, ich gehe ohne was zu kaufen, nach dem Kommentar, das geht nicht. Ich kann nicht sagen, ich brauche nichts, danke. Also greife ich mir eine Flasche und sage dann ja, die Winteredition und dann meinte er, ah ja, okay, muss ich mal gucken, ob ich die bestelle. Und dachte ich mir, um Gottes Willen, wenn der jetzt extra wegen mir da vier Kästen... Lebensmittel, da kannst du nicht so einen Buchmarkt Move machen, Buchhandlung, wo man hingeht und sagen, wir können es bis morgen bestellen, immer insane auch. Ich hätte so ein schlechtes Gewissen gehabt. Aber da geht es, in Buchhandlungen geht es, weil man Buch in der Regel nicht normal, nicht sofort braucht. Du kaufst ja nicht gleich einen ganzen Kasten Bücher, so du hast ja nicht irgendwie so gleich hundert Bücher. Ja, aber auch, weil du kaufst ein Getränk, um es sofort zu trinken. Ich finde, dass er diese Idee hat, bis morgen kann ich es bestellen, finde ich merkwürdig. Ja, das hat er auch so nicht gesagt, er hat gesagt, er guckt es sich mal an, aber dann hatte ich ein mega schlechtes Gewissen, weil ich dachte nicht, dass er jetzt wegen mir da hundert Kästen Wintereditionen machte, also ein ganzes letztes Erspartes da reinsteckt. Und niemand trinkt diesen Scheiß außer dir. Die Winteredition. Und seitdem gucke ich wirklich jedes Mal, wenn ich da vorbeilauf, ganz schüchtern rein, ob der die im Regal hat. Und wenn der die im Regal hat, werde ich da reingehen und sage, ich kaufe alle. Ich nehme alle. Hat, aber hat er nicht. Gibt es ja immer noch jetzt, die Winteredition? Ich habe sie nirgendwo gefunden dieses Jahr. Dieses Jahr war ein ganz, ganz düsteres, trockenes Jahr.
Ist die ein bisschen Spekulatius.
Ja, ein bisschen Spekulatius, ein bisschen spekulativ, ein bisschen Ton.
Bisschen spekulativ? Ist es eine Weihnachtedition oder eine Winteredition?
Winteredition, ja, Winteredition. Bisschen zimtig, bisschen herber und keine Ahnung, was das heißt, aber die mache ich eigentlich immer ganz gern.
Und ich kenne einen Laden in München, wo ich die verlässlich kriege,
aber bin ich halt selten.
Okay, da kann man ja mal
vielleicht einen Umweg machen.
Ich werde diesen Laden meiden müssen, echt, ich bin da
Aber sagt er denn immer noch den gleichen Spruch?
Immer noch, immer Leckermate, jedes Mal
und ich bin immer noch scheißleckermate,
das kannst du vergessen. Furchtbar.
Aber wie gesagt, dann finde ich es eigentlich ganz gut, wenn man jetzt langsam mal die Hausaufgabe wieder erwärmt und du sagst zeitgleich mit ihm lecker mate. Weil das sagt vieles aus. Wenn du lecker mate und ihm gleichzeitig sagst, er tappst du ihn auf frischer Tat, er wird merken, fuck, das habe ich zu häufig gesagt, mein cooler Spruch ist aufgeflogen. Erkennt er dich mittlerweile denn eigentlich als Stammkunden?
Aber das ist halt so, du kannst Leuten
auch ihren Catchphrase nicht geben. Das ist so, wie wenn du
wenn irgendwie Barney,
wenn irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die Tröte geht,
dass die Arbeit vorbei ist bei Fred Feuerstein
und dann sagt Barney,
Jabba-dabba-do. Gott sei Dank hast du das Franchise
erwähnt. Ich war gerade bei How I Met Your Mother,
aber ich glaube,
welche Tröte bei der Arbeit, okay.
Dann sagt Barney,
Jabba-dabba-do und Fred Feuerstein schaut mit
Die erwähnen. Ich war gerade bei How I Met Your Mother, aber ich glaube, welche Tröte bei der Arbeit, okay. Dann sagt Barney, Jabba-dabba-du und Fred Feuerstein schaut ihn mit leeren Augen an und sagt, das wollte ich gerade sagen, und hat nichts mehr, schaut in die Kamera und sagt, was soll das eigentlich? Wir können doch nicht in dem Pelikan unseren Zement mischen. Oder Barney kommt in seinem Anzug in die Bar und Ted sagt, suit up. So, geht auch nicht. Ja, ja, ja. Gut. Ja, nee, das stimmt. Und dann, du kannst, nimm den Leuten ihr Catchphrase nicht. Sei im Gegenteil sogar froh, dass sie ein Catchphrase haben. Aber ist das nicht auch ein Mashup, How I Met Your Mother und Barney Geröllheimer? Also Barney Geröllheimer als Barney in How I Met Your Mother finde ich stark. Gibt es nicht noch einen Barney, dieser Dino Barney? Ja, Barney und dann gibt es noch natürlich... Könnte ich mal alle Barneys aus fiktionalen Kontexten zusammen eine Serie machen? Apropos Crossover. Wie lange muss ich jetzt reden, bis es apropos nicht mehr passt? Ich bin sehr tolerant, was apropos angeht. Also auch von Sachen aus, drei Folgen. Apropos Crossover, wir haben immer noch unsere grosse Crossover Kurzgeschichten-Challenge am Laufen, wo ihr uns einige Geschichten geschickt habt und erfolgreiche Universen miteinander vermischt und vermengt und rührt und unterhebt und man nicht weiß, was dabei tatsächlich rauskommt. Nee, bei Unterheben weiß man natürlich einfach auch nicht, was genau passiert. Und hier kommt die nächste Geschichte und zwar von Philipp. Ich sag mal nicht, welche Universen hier gemischt werden, vielleicht kommst du selber drauf. Kann ich das Universum jeweils dann reinrufen, wenn es kommt? Ja, bitte reinrufen und auch hier zu Hause, sobald ihr es denkt zu wissen, ruft bitte ganz. Brüllt, es soll laut ihr könnt, nur dann haben wir eine Chance, es zu hören.
Hier ist die Geschichte von Philipp.
Das letzte Quartal war eine einzige Enttäuschung.
Die Geldreserven waren noch immer beachtlich, jedoch wurde der Speicher auch nicht weiter gefüllt.
Stillstand ist Rückschritt.
Bitte was?
Stillstand ist Rückschritt. Ein Zitat vonchritt. So konnte es nicht weitergehen. Mit der Wut im Bauch, die durch das letzte Gebettel der Neffen auch nicht gerade kleiner geworden war, setzte sich der alte Mann also seinen Schreibtisch und verfasste einen Brief. Lieber Walter, wie kann das passieren? Ich weiss, die letzten Monate waren hart, aber deine Gesundheit kann nicht immer die Ausrede sein. Mir wurden die Diagnosen deiner Ärzte von einem gemeinsamen bekannten Anwalt zugestickt. Sieht für mich alles in Ordnung aus. Und ja, ich weiß, dass die Umsätze deines blauen Meths immer noch marktführend sind. Ich habe schon ein paar Brille-Geschreie gehört.
Aber die Mexikaner kommen uns nahe. Und die haben nicht nur Crystal im Angebot, sondern verfügen auch über eine weitere gefächerte Produktpalette. Und bei diesen Projekten bist du ja nicht gerade eine Hilfe. Ich verstehe, dass man als Chemiker nicht auch Biologe ist, allerdings hat mich das Labor,
inklusive aller Cutting-Edge-Technologien da drin ein kleines Vermögen gekostet. Und bei Gott, ich bin im Gewinngeschäft und nicht im Investmentgeschäft. Krieg das also auf die Reihe. Mir egal wie, werde partnerlos, senke Beschaffungskosten oder optimiere das Rezept. Mir egal wie, regel das.
Auf ein gewinnbringendes neues Quartal, hochachtungsvoll, Dagobert Duck.
Okay, also ein Mashup aus Ein Mathup.
Fantastisch, ein Mathup aus Breaking Bad und die Tigerenten,
die Entenhausen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Dagobert Duck
bei Gott sagen würde. Bei Gott!
Ist es auch die Frage, weil das
erklärt man, man ergründet nicht genau, wie
der Rest der Welt aussieht.
Weil jetzt immer in Bayblade
Dimensionen zu denken, wo Moses mit einem Beyblade das Meer geteilt hat. Nee, ein grosser... Moses hat mit einem Beyblade das Meer geteilt. Ein Moses-förmiger Beyblade, der Beyblade Moses. Das macht es noch cooler, wenn Moses selber Beyblade wäre, aber naja, ich will es auch nicht an der Lore kratzen. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, wie der Gott aussähe bei Inendenhausen. Ja, das ist die Frage, das ist natürlich die Frage. Und ich glaube, Philipp hat da natürlich einen uralten narrativen Kniff angewandt, der gute alte Trick des Briefs, um diese zwei Dimensionen zu trennen, um zu sagen, die eine Dimension schreibt einen Brief an die andere, um die nicht unnötig zu vermischen zu müssen. Und auch um das Konzept Pointe, gleich Unterschrift, gleich erst dann kommt es raus, zu wahren. Ja, sehr, sehr gut gemacht, also wirklich ein Meister. Stilistisch toll. Des Smash-Ups. Bin ich ein Fan dieses Smash-Ups? Ja. Nein. Ne, ich auch nicht, ich glaube, da bleibt viel auf der Strecke, aber sie war kurz. Und das ist das, wonach wir suchen. Wonach du suchst. Kurzgeschickt. Du bist diese Frau. Werbung. Wie alle wissen, das letzte Jahr war ziemlich stressig und chaotisch und es wird wahrscheinlich in diesem Jahr auch noch so ein bisschen so weitergehen.
Und da ist es besonders wichtig, dass man möglichst alle bürokratischen Sachen entspannt und locker angehen kann.
Ich will keinen Stress mehr, Florentin.
Ich will keinen Stress mehr, ich will das alles auf einen Blick haben, dass ich mich zumindest um den Kram nicht mehr kümmern muss.
Ich habe mir vorgenommen, in diesem Jahr einfach stressfrei durchs Leben zu gehen.
Und weißt du, womit ich anfange? Mit Clark.
Ah.
Alle Versicherungen im Blick, mein digitaler Versicherungsmanager.
Weil Versicherungen sind, machen wir uns nichts vor, pain in the ass.
Vor allem in unserem Alter, wenn die Eltern haben noch so ein paar Versicherungen für einen, man weiß nicht, wo liegt was, wo ist man versichert, einfach mal einmal die Mühe geben, Clark runterzuladen, alle Versicherungen reinzuladen, dann weiss man genau, wo man versichert ist, was anfällt, wo was abläuft und du kannst neue Versicherungen abschliessen. Du brauchst da nicht mehr irgendwelche Aktenordner voller Briefe, sondern kannst einfach in deiner App alles einfügen, einmal dort eintragen und dann hast du da alles in Übersicht. Und als kleine Schmackern obendrauf gibt es noch einen kleinen Bonus, und zwar mit dem Gutscheincode UFO15 bekommt ihr für jede bestehende Versicherung, die ihr in die App ladet, einen 15 Euro Amazon-Gutschein bis zu einem Maximum von 30. Völlig richtig. Also, Kl Clark muss erladen und ab geht die wilde Fahrt. Kein Papierkram mehr. Die ruhige Fahrt. Die ruhige, stressfreie Fahrt. Mit Clark. Werbung. Es hat schon viele Leute bei Florentina auch gefragt, ob er mal Hörbücher einlesen kann. Und Gegenfrage immer, Gegenmail ist immer, wie lang ist es
denn? Weil du willst,
irgendwann ist es dir zu lang, du bist lesefaul.
Du willst kurze Geschichten einlesen.
Das ist wirklich, das ist eine
der schlimmsten Arbeiten, glaube ich, die es
geben kann, ein komplettes Buch einzulesen.
Ich finde es perfekt.
Wirklich? Ja, ich lese super gerne vor.
Aber mehrere Takes,
den ganzen Tag lang, du hast das Buch nicht gecheckt, du musst immer gucken, wer spricht gerade.
Das Buch nicht gecheckt. Ich lese mich Tenet vorlesen, ich will irgendein Buch vorlesen. Ich will nicht rückwärts lesen müssen. Es gibt verschiedene Figuren und denen gibst du verschiedene Stimmen, da musst du immer alles im Kopf behalten. Vor allem muss man manchmal schon am Satz anfangen wissen, das frage ich mich bei Christian Ullmans Hitchhiker's Guide Through the Galaxy, frage ich mich wirklich, wie der manchmal am Satzanfang schon wissen kann, wer das gesprochen hat. Ich habe der Geschichte nicht mehr zuhören können, weil ich derzeit dachte, wie macht er das bloß, bis mir dann einfiel, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht live war. Er liest mir das gerade nicht live ein. Kann sein. Ja, genau. Vielen Dank für die Geschichte, Philipp. Ja, ich habe ja mal, ich wollte ja mal ein Buch einlesen. Da gibt es ja so eine offene Plattform, LibriVox heißt die, wo alle Leute alle Bücher einlesen können. Und dazu muss es Copyright frei sein, glaube ich. Und da werden dann halt so die Klassiker eingelesen und so. Und ich habe mir mal ein Buch gewünscht zu Weihnachten, habe auch ein Buch mit dem Titel bekommen, das ich mir gewünscht habe. Es war aber ein anderes Buch, das denselben Titel hatte. Und das Buch hieß Auf verlorenen Posten. Und es war ein ganz schäbiger Science-Fiction-Roman, den ich nicht haben wollte, aber bekommen habe zu Weihnachten und dachte mir, okay, dann nutze ich diese Gelegenheit und lese das ein und habe tatsächlich ein Kapitel von diesem schäbigen Science-Fiction-Roman eingelesen. Ein Kapitel! Ein Kapitel eingelesen, weil genau das war mein Problem. Ich nie wusste, wer gerade spricht und mir dann eigentlich mit dem Textmarker mit fünf verschiedenen Farben alles durchlesen musste. Und dann irgendwelche Cyborgs und irgendwelche Kreaturen, so Lurchmenschen, wie spricht man die aus, dann die ganzen Fachbegriffe, wie spricht man die aus? Cybercore, so was ist das alles? Das hat mich wahnsinnig gemacht. Deswegen habe ich es gelassen und Librevox einen guten Titel vorenthalten. Tut mir leid, alle Sci-Fi-Fans. Auf verlorenen Posten. Auf verlorenen Posten, ja, ging gar nicht weiter. Dabei klingt das eigentlich wie ein fantastischer Sci-Fi. Es klingt eigentlich fantastisch, aber ich glaube, es gibt tatsächlich auch manche Bücher, die haben mehrere Titel. Also da weiss man nicht, was man kriegt dann letzten Endes. Wenn man sich irgendwas wünscht, kriegt man einfach eins davon, zufällig. Ich habe jetzt übers Wochenende die gesamte Alien-Reihe geguckt, das gesamte Alien-Franchise. Hat auch Quatschfilme da drin, unglaubliche Scheissfilme. Wie viele sind das denn? Alien, Aliens, Alien 3, Alien Resurrection, Prometheus, Some More Aliens, Alien Covenant, und dann die Alien vs. Predator-Teile gehören nicht dazu. Ich wiederhole, die Alien vs. Predator-Teile gehören nicht zum Alien-Franchise. Das ist gesondert. Das ist nicht Kanon. Es gibt aber oft noch so illegitime Nachfolge und Spin-Offs, die man gar nicht kennt. Wie man ja auch zum Beispiel bei Disney Plus oder so sich angucken kann, wo es zu jedem Pixar-Film noch mal drei weitere Filme gibt, irgendwelche Spin-Offs, Musicals, was auch immer. Zu jedem Film gibt es noch mal, es gibt die Schöne und das Biest Musical, einfach zusätzlich. Das kennt niemand, das wurde halt so nebenbei produziert fürs Fernsehen, lief wahrscheinlich in dem Kino. Und das gibt es einfach noch mal dazu. Zu jedem Film gibt es noch mal hundert andere Filme, die kein Mensch kennt. Das ist total spannend. Das war unsere Werbung, jetzt geht es weiter mit dem Podcast. Die man sich alle angucken kann. Aber vielleicht ist es bei Aliens auch so. Du kennst halt nur Alien, Aliens, More Aliens, Aliens in Space, Aliens in Outer Space. Das letzte Teil aber auch. That's the last one, we promise Aliens. Versprochen, es kommt kein Teil mehr, Aliens. Und dann gibt es aber noch die ganzen Musical und die Highschool-Aliens und sowas. Aliens und Highschool- Highschool-Musical fände ich auch toll. Alter, vor allem die können ja auch zweistimmig singen, die haben ja zwei Münder. Das ist ja geil, der Plot schreibt sich ja von selbst, Talent-Show in Highschool-Musical, alle wollen Talent haben und das Alien kann als einziges doppelstimmig singen und gewinnt die Talent-Show. Ja, vor allem dann, ich sehe jetzt schon den Tony Award für den Hauptdarsteller, der seine Arie singt. Ja, zweistimmig. Und dann kommt aber irgendwann dieser Facehugger drauf und dann kann er nochmal mit einer anderen Stimme aus Sicht des Facehuggers oder ich stelle mir vor sogar, ich stelle mir vor, ein Spotlight auf den Musicaldarsteller und er kämpft mit diesem Facehugger und es ist ein Duett, aber er singt
alleine, aber hat dann diesen Facehugger,
den er ab und zu schafft, abzureissen von sich,
singt dann gegen diesen
Facehugger, dann sitzt der Facehugger drauf und dann fängt der Facehugger
aus seiner Sicht seine Familiengeschichte zu erklären und so weiter
und es ist ein großes Duett
und da bricht irgendwann aus dem Bauch noch der
Wurm raus, die auch noch mitsingt.
Mit zwei Mündern mitsingt, also es ist
fantastisch. Als Quartett dann letzten Endes.
Letzten Endes ist es dann doch ein Quartett.
Du brauchst halt Vierlinge.
Du musst halt Vierlinge casten.
Das ist das Problem.
Naja, du brauchst halt Vierlinge, die alle gut singen und gut tanzen können und die dann einfach die ähnliche Stimme haben und dann zusammen singen.
Weißt du, was ich übrigens machen würde?
Wenn ich Drillinge bekommen würde, ich würde die irgendwie benennen.
Tick, trick und tack nennen. Tick,illinge bekommen würde, ich würde die irgendwie benennen, Tick, Tick,
Trick und Rainer.
Irgendwie so benennen,
dass du einfach genau weißt,
irgendwie Flip, Flop und Gustav.
Und dann einfach so, Flip, Flop, Gustav,
kommt ihr bitte! Und die sehen alle drei exakt
gleich aus, einer grün, einer blau, einer gelb.
Oder Oin, Gloin und Tick.
Oder du hast... Oder Oin, Tick und Dipsy. Crossover. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Oder du hast ein Zwillingspaar und dann noch zwei andere Kinder. Und die beiden anderen Kinder heißen irgendwie Tipp und Tapp. Und die Zwillinge heißen Gustav und Harald. Die haben ganz normale Namen, aber die, die nicht Zwillinge sind, haben irgendwie so Combo-Namen. Das finde ich auch gut.
Ich werde damals mal mit einer Familie befreundet, muss ich jetzt einfach mal vor und nach Namen sagen, aber die hießen von Voss, Familie von Voss. Toller Name. Cool. Und die hatten erst, hatten die Zwillinge bekommen, dann haben sie noch mal Kinder bekommen, sie war wieder schwanger, haben wieder Zwillinge bekommen, und dann
war sie noch mal schwanger, und es kam nur einer.
Und der heißt Einer.
Der heißt jetzt Einer. Einer?
Und er heißt nicht nur Einer, er heißt Einer von Voss.
Das ist der beste
Das ist ja fantastisch. Name
der ganzen Welt.
Es kam nur Einer, er heißt Einer,
er heißt Einer von Voss. Alles daran ist fantastisch. Das fünfte Kind ist ja natürlich prädestiniert für Gagnamen. Ich glaube, beim fünften Kind ist es eh schon egal. Dem kannst du Gagnamen. Du hast auch das Konzept Name überwunden als etwas, was jetzt so wichtig ist, wo es sich wert ist, viel Gedanken zu machen. Am Ende heißt es halt jeder irgendwie. Glaubst du, du wärst ein anderer Mensch, wenn ich Markus heißen würde, du wärst ein anderer Mensch, wenn du Fabian heißen würdest. Glaubst du da wirklich dran? Nein. Es ist einfach nur Hülsen, Namen sind Hülsen. Weiß ich nicht. Ehrlich gesagt, denke ich das Gegenteil. Ich glaube, ich wär ein anderer Mensch, wenn ich anders heißen würde. Du kannst gerne nochmal die andere Position mitziehen. Auf gar keinen Fall ist man doch ein anderer Mensch. Du bist ja in dir selbst drin, als ob der Name was verändert. Genauso gut kann es aber sein, dass es sehr viel mit einem macht. Ich bin sehr flexibel, was diese Meinung anbelangt. Ich glaube, es ist schon ein Unterschied, ob du einen Spitznamen hast oder nicht. Ob du so einen Namen hast, wo du einen Spitznamen hast. Wo du Urs heisst, ist schwer einen Spitznamen für dich zu finden. Wohingegen, wenn du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, immer Buffy genannt wirst, glaube ich, bist du automatisch der Coole. Du kannst nicht uncool sein, wenn du einen coolen Namen hast, wenn du Moe bist oder so. Ja, ich denke mir, weil Arne, Arne Feldhusen, liebe Kollege, sagt die ganze Zeit, er hatte Probleme in seinem Namen, weil er immer Arne-Banane genannt wurde. Aber dann denke ich mir, das ist doch wirklich nicht schlimm. Wenn Arne-Banane der Gipfel der Frechheit ist, der dir in der Schulzeit entgegensprüht, dann hast du doch wirklich andere Probleme. Das ist doch nichts Schlimmes. Arne-Banane. Ja, stimmt schon, aber Arne-Bana-... Ja, so what? Ja, gut, aber es stimmt schon. Es kann natürlich, es kann hart sein. Kommt halt darauf an, wie du zu Bananen stehst. Arne Banane ist hart? Ne, es ist nicht hart, aber es ist schon, du willst halt ernst genommen werden und Banane ist nicht ernst zu nehmen. Banane ist lächerlich. Wie ist eine Banane lächerlich? Banane, guck dir die mal an, lang und gelb, was soll das? Lächerlich. Manche vibrieren, das ist doch ein Witz. Aber das war zum Beispiel, fand ich auch mal gut. Manche sind Kerzen. Das fand ich auch gut. Nochmal auf meiner Zivi-Zeit, wo wir immer die Kinder ermahnen mussten, wenn sie geflucht haben. Das sagt man nicht. Wenn sie verdorrig noch eins gesagt haben. Genau, und die haben teilweise so niedlich geflucht und sich beschimpft. Du dumme Rübe! Lea, das sagen wir aber nicht! Das sagt man generell seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr. Und er muss es so immer... Wow, 1980 angerufen, wir sind Fünfer da zurück. Meine Oma hat angerufen, wir sind Gemüse zurück. Du hast jemanden Rübe gesehen in deinem Leben. Und da muss man die immer ihre Lampe zurück. Hä? Ja, anderes Thema, anderes Gag-Franchise. Aber da musste man immer richtig hart sein, obwohl die immer so ganz niedliche Sachen sagen, du dummer Fisch, Lisa, das sagen wir hier aber nicht. Und die Fische so, wir sind genau neben euch. Das sagen wir nicht. Ja, nee, sagen wir hier nicht. Wieso nicht? Was ist denn so schlimm an Fischen? Es geht darum, wie du es gesagt hast. Warum gibt es überhaupt Fische im Kindergarten? Das ist der schlechteste Ort. Die ganze Zeit werden in die Dinge reingeworfen. Ich habe mich mit Legostein verschluckt. Wurde mir erklärt, als ich da angefangen habe, und zwar war das so eine Nachmittagstagesstätte. Moment, es gab wirklich ein Aquarium? Es gab wirklich ein Aquarium und es wurde strategisch platziert. Ich erkläre dir wie. Ich habe nicht nachgefragt. Ich erkläre dir trotzdem wie. Und zwar war das so aufgebaut, da gab es dann auch so verschiedene Ebenen aus Holz, wo man rumklettern konnte und so. Und es gab aber eine Engstelle in diesem Raum. Es war ein länglicher Raum und da gab es eine Engstelle und da stand genau das Aquarium. Moment, war das Aquarium die Engstelle? Ja, es stand direkt an der Engstelle. Und der Erzieher hat mir erklärt, die Idee ist ... Kannst du nicht einfach sagen, was diese Engstelle ist? Engstelle sozusagen, was eine Wand, Regal? Nein, es war halt, keine Ahnung, der Raum war halt so gebaut, dass da halt eine Engstelle war. Ja, okay, gut. Und dann hat der Erzieher zu mir gemeint, die Idee von dieser Engstelle ist, dass die Kinder vor dem Aquarium stehen bleiben, um die Fische anzuschauen, damit sie anderen Kindern im Weg stehen, damit andere Kinder sagen müssen, du lass mich mal kurz vorbei, um die Kinder zu zwingen, zu interagieren und Höflichkeitsformeln und wie man Probleme löst zu lernen, damit die sich möglichst viel im Weg stehen. Leider sind beim grossen Brand 2013 alle Kinder auf das Leben gekommen. Und alle Fische auch. Und alle Fische. Die Fische konnten nicht gerettet werden. Weil es an dieser Engenstelle zu einer Massenpanik ankam. Oder die Feuerwehr hat impulsiv eher die Fische gerettet und leider die Kinder verbrennt. Kam nicht rein. Sorry, das war eine spontane Entscheidung. Da kam doch rein, da war diese Engenstelle, da waren die Fische, wir wussten nicht. Aber das fand ich eine interessante Idee, zu sagen, wir bauen diesen Raum so manipulativ, um die Kinder zu zwingen, dass sie interagieren müssen, dass sie eben nicht einfach außen rumgehen können, sondern dass sie sagen müssen, lass mich kurz vorbei. Natürlich wurde es ständig geprügelt. Ende von nichts war doch wahrscheinlich einfach nur, du hast so typisch deutschen Arschlöcher, diese passiv-aggressiven Arschlöcher herangezüchtet. Ja, dieses Stehen wir wieder im Weg, gucken wir wieder die Fische an. Diese Fische. Gucken wir, ob der Blaue heute wieder von rechts nach links schwimmt. Ja, diese Fische haben so viel Gewalt und so viel Sass gesehen, wie sonst niemand in diesem ganzen Gebäude. Die Fische waren nicht so, sorry, ich bin so leer vorbei. Machen sich ganz, die Flundern haben sich ganz schmal gemacht. Ja, einfach vorbeigern. Ist das so die Entwicklung von Social Awkwardness, die Flunder, die einfach sagt so, sorry, sorry, sorry, ganz schmal. Aber geil, die steht niemand im Weg. Außer sie dreht sich falsch herum, sie steht massiv im Weg. Dann können sie richtig viel blockieren, stimmt schon. Wie so eine Tür. So ein Parkplatz zu rückwärts einparken als Flunder ist, muss die Hölle sein.
Ich habe Aalreusen nicht
verstanden.
Aalreusen, auch toll, das ist dafür
ein eigenes Wort. Aalreuse.
Die sind ja
toll geformt auch. Es sind diese Schläuche
und dann werden die
immer in eine Richtung schmaler,
weil die Aale können nur in eine Richtung
schwimmen, die können nicht rückwärts schwimmen. Und so müssen sie, werden sie einfach langsam in diesem Geflecht gefangen. Das ist wie das einfachst zu lösenste Labyrinth der Welt und die sind trotzdem verloren, weil sie nicht rückwärts schwimmen können. Und weil es immer schmaler wird zwischendurch, sind sie dann einfach darin gefangen. Aber die können dann nicht auf dem Rücken sich drehen, nee, das hilft nicht. Das hilft gar nicht. Das hilft überhaupt nicht. Nur alles einmal umgedreht. Das könnten sie aber schon. Die können schon wie so eine Spirelli. Ja, da hängen sich da am falschen Detail. Wie so eine Spirelli könnten die sich einfach wie so eine Schraube. Die können sich wie eine Kritschnecke schrauben. Können die sich da reinschrauben. Aber das würde ihre Lage nur noch verschlimmern. Sorry an alle Aale, die gerade zuhören. An Aale. Und die ich jetzt gerade mal weiter reingerutscht habe ins Problem. Schwierig. Aalreuse. Aber es ist auch ein ungünstiges Tier, das nicht rückwärts schwimmen kann, oder? Es gibt, glaube ich, viele Tiere, die nicht rückwärts gehen können. Känguru zum Beispiel? Känguru kann auch nicht rückwärts gehen. Du könntest auch eine Kängurufalle bauen. Einfach so ein attraktives Aquarium am Ende von so einem Gang, der sich immer weiter verjügend. Und das Känguru kommt weiter und weiter und steckt irgendwann fest und kommt nicht mehr raus. Und kann sich dann auch nicht mehr reinschrauben wie ein Aal. Das könnte sich nicht drehen. Das könnte sich nicht. Also hätte dem Aal auch nicht geholfen, aber auch das Känguru. Ja, genau. Könnte es auch nicht machen. Kann es auch nicht machen. Nee, ist schwierig. Ich glaube, ist es sogar nicht in der, in der ... Ist es ein Urban Myth eigentlich, diese Beutel? Ja. Ja, das ist ein kompletter Bullshit. Kompletter Bullshit. Das ist irgendwie so ein Kinderspielzeughersteller, der irgendwie da so einen Beutel vorne dran hatte. Seitdem ist das ein Mythos. Ich glaube, Coca-Cola hat den Weihnachtsmann erfunden, Pepsi hat diesen Kängurubeutel erfunden. Weil da früher dann in der Werbung so eine Dose drin war. Ja, das war ja so eine Werbung für Bauchtaschen. So Bauchtaschen, wo die Menschheit gesagt hat, wir müssen unseren emotionalen Rückstand aufholen mit dieser Bauchtasche. Evolutional, eigentlich ein gutes Wort, was wir gerade erfunden haben. Stell dir vor, wir Menschen hätten eine Bauchtasche und trotzdem noch einen Pullover an. Würden wir die trotzdem nutzen oder nicht? Boah, das wäre so unpraktisch. Das kann ja, weil viele Sachen werden ja obsolet, wenn eine Spezies zu clever wird. Ja. Aber ich glaube, wir können auch so einen Schnorchel auf dem Kopf haben, um unter Wasser atmen zu müssen. Leider hat sich halt unser Leben, vor allem an Land spielt sich jetzt ab, wenn wir noch ein Steißbein, weil wir noch so einen Schwanzanhängsel haben. Wir könnten auch, hätten wir zum Beispiel keinen Cap erfunden, hätten wir vielleicht so einen Hautlappen, den wir bei Bedarf so nach vorne klappen können, der dann uns vor der Sonne schützt. Aber wenn wir ihn nicht brauchen, klappen wir ihn wieder so zurück auf den Kopf. Könnte auch passieren. Zum Glück haben wir die Basecap erfunden, die uns vor diesem Schicksal... Haben wir trotzdem die Basecap erfunden? Ja. Ich glaube, der Mensch hätte aber Hosentaschen, Haut-Hosentaschen, so an den Beinen. So Cargo-Pants-Taschen, so unten an den Beinen. Aber wie uncool ist das, wenn man dann Hosen anzieht, haben die dann Aussparungen an der Stelle, damit wir trotzdem unsere Haut nutzen können? Oder wie sehen unsere Hosen aus?
Vielleicht ist in der Hose dann keine Hosentasche.
Du willst ja nicht in dein nacktes Bein langen,
um dann da deinen Schlüssel rauszukramen.
Du willst die Schlüssel ja trotzdem noch draußen im Bein haben.
Wie diese eine Alienrasse,
die diese Bauchtasche hat und darüber einfach
ein Hoodie trägt. Ja, das ist
fehlkonstruiert.
Und die wird auch nicht, die geht evolutionär
halt auch nicht weg. Kann man aktiv was evolutionär wegschaufeln? Das ist ja meine große Theorie. Ich glaube nicht mehr. Habe ich Beweise dafür? Nein. Aber ich habe das Gefühl. Stefan, ich habe das Gefühl, du schwimmst gerade in einen sehr engen Gang rein. Der wird immer enger gerade, aber schwimm ruhig mal weiter. Ich kann auch nicht rückwärtschwimmen, aber ich merke, ich drehe mich mal kurz im Kreis. Weil ich glaube, Evolution heißt ja, ich weiß, wir waren da schon mal ein paar Folgen. Noch kannst du umdrehen, aber du schwimmst weiter. Evolution heißt ja Survival of the fittest. Und du bist so tief drin. Jetzt habe ich es gesagt. Survival of the fittest. Der Angepasste gewinnt, weil der sich am ehesten fortpflanzt. Deswegen sind Eisbären ja weiss, weil die überlebt haben in der in der Arktis oder Arktis. Schnee? Hier das Richtige. Ich bin im Schnee. Ja. Weil die im Schnee sich gut tarnen. Sehr gut. Deswegen haben die überlebt und konnten sich fortpflanzen. Darum geht es ja. Der Mensch jetzt heutzutage heilt ja alle Krankheiten. Heißt, wir rotten ja auch wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr schlimme Krankheiten aus, aus unseren Genen, weil nicht mehr die überleben, die die Krankheit überwunden haben oder gar nicht in sich tragen, weil bei uns überleben ja auch die, die ein weirdes Gen in sich haben. Wenn du jetzt eine Krankheit in deinem... Dieser Gentest, den du einmal gemacht hast... Du bist ein Mensch unabhängig von deinen Genen. Nur weil du jetzt ein paar Bananengene drin hast... Das ist vielleicht das Schlauste, was ich jemals gesagt habe. Pass mal auf. Du sagst, wir sollen die Schwachen umbringen, weil die Evolution nicht mehr dazu in der Lage sind. So schwachen Machen wie ich, mit Trichterbrust. Überleben ja. Früher wären wir totgetrampelt worden, weil wir nicht hinterher joggen, weil wir nicht vor den Löwen, ich weiß nicht, ob das jemals ein Problem war bei der Menschheit, aber wir konnten nicht vor den Löwen weg joggen, weil unser Herz plattgedrückt wird von unseren Trichterbrüsten. Mich gibt es aber, weil ... Ich glaube, da sind wir froh, dass es sich gibt. Ja, weil wir diese Probleme nicht mehr haben. Ich zeige jetzt trotzdem noch ein Kind und das Kind kriegt eine Trichterbrust. Diese Krankheit bleibt bestehen. Ich glaube, wir haben einfach die Evolution, ist jetzt vorbei. Der Mensch entwickelt sich nicht mehr weiter, weil wir züchten nichts mehr weg oder sowas. Ist dem noch denn so? Hört da draußen noch jemand zu? Nein, die Leute sind weg. Sie sind abgehauen. Sämtliche Zuschauer haben den Raum verlassen, Herr Dietze, weil sie auf andere Fragen antworten, als sie dich in Stelle. Es geht hier um die Trump-Wahl. Ich weiß, ich bin hier um mein Buch Trump zu besprechen. Trotzdem wollte ich jetzt mal kurz darauf eingehen, weil mir das einfällt. Naja, die Frage ist halt, was die Merkmale sind, die überhaupt noch relevant sind. Das ist die Frage. Aber ob die Trichterbrust so wild ist, ach, das wird schon. Das wird schon. Glaubst du, die Natur sagt manchmal so, ach, das wird schon. Ja, im Grunde ist es ja auch nicht ganz korrekt, dass das überlebt, was am besten angepasst ist, sondern dass das ausstirbt, was am wenigsten angepasst ist. Das heißt, so die unteren zehn Prozent fliegen immer raus. Und wenn du diese Hauttaschen hast, die jetzt aber auch nicht stören, dann gehen die auch nicht weg. Weil dann bleiben die halt, wenn die kein Grund sind dafür, dass du ausstirbst. Ich will nicht mal sehen, wie du dich vorstranst mit den Hautlappen, links und rechts. Du, ich bin froh, dass wir das nicht haben, dass es ein Tier getroffen hat, das die Tasche bekommen hat. Und dass sie auch keinen Tintisch schießen können, sondern dass die Tintenfische bekommen haben, sondern die haben die Tasche bekommen. Finde ich schon ganz praktisch eigentlich. Warum hat nicht ein Tier so zwei Gimmicks? Warum hat jedes Tier so ein Gimmick? Hasen können springen und haben lange Ohren. Übervorteilt, ja. Ich behaupte, jedes Tier hat im Schnitt ein Gimmick. Was ist das Tier mit den meisten Gimmicks? Ich glaube schon ... Dieser Anglerfisch mit dieser Lampe vorhanden. Nee, ich glaube schon Krake. Die können so krass ... Zwei Hirne, nee, Herzen. Acht Hirne, in den Tentakeln haben die auch noch mal Hirne. Und wachsen nach, wenn die Tentakeln verlieren. Acht Hirne, zwei ... Wir fassen zusammen. Acht Hirne, acht Arme, ein Schnabel, Saugnäpfe, ein Schnabel, zwei Herzen, zwei Herzen, sind super clever, keine Hosentaschen, keine Tentakeltaschen, das sind ein Riesenvorteil, die wir zählen auf, die sie haben, die sie haben, nicht die sie nicht haben, und nicht so einen dummen Hut auf oder so, der sie irgendwie im Schwimmen behindert oder so, und Tinte können die spürzen. Nicht so einen Fallschirm oder sowas. Tinte. Tinte können die und die können halt sich auch die Hautfarbe ändern, was halt ultra krass ist. Warum haben die alles bekommen? Haben alles! Kraken haben alles! Und daneben ist dieser normale silberne Fisch, der so denkt, sorry, ich hab nichts. Ich hab gar nichts. Für mich gibt es Millionen Menschen, äh, Fische, die im Schwarm rumeiern, die werden gefressen von diesen Overskilled-MVP-Oktopussen. Ja, die sind OP. Und die haben 19 Namen. Kraken, Oktopus, Tentakelmeister, Tentakel-Saugnapfie. So, die haben so viele verschiedene Namen. Ja, das ist schwierig. Ich sage eben, wir haben keine Chance. Langfristig haben wir keine Chance. Kann schon sein, ich habe heute Morgen, war ich bei Clubhouse unterwegs. Übrigens müssen wir bei dieser App, tut mir leid, mal sprechen, weil, und ich weiß, das behaupte ich bei jeder App, die Erfolg hat, aber ich habe die erfunden. Und es haben sogar ein paar Hörer, haben mir sogar ein Timecode geschickt. Ich glaube, es war Folge 114. Ja, na ja. Du hast eine App erfunden, die hieß das Podcast-Ufo und hatte zum Inhalt, dass man gemeinsam Dinge anschauen kann. Also so eine Art Audio-Flick, aber für alles. Ich habe gesagt, Live-Podcasts, Live-Gespräche, in denen man sich reinschalten kann und zuhören kann. Jeder kann sich in dieser App anmelden, man kann sich folgen und jeder kann auch sprechen in der App.
Ja, aber du hattest es bezogen auf
irgendein Live-Event. Es läuft ein
Fussballspiel und alle tun sich zusammen,
gucken gemeinsam das Fussballspiel und tauschen sich aus.
Genau. So wird es ja jetzt auch
genutzt, primär, also
so Trash-TV zusammen gucken, Filme gucken. Ja, aber die Idee,
Leute sprechen miteinander, ist doch so grob,
da kannst du doch jetzt keinen Copyright-Art drauf anmelden.
Du willst Cash. Wie viel Cash willst du?
Ich will nur die Credits
im Sinne von Anerkennung.
Ich will nur im Pressum
erwähnt werden.
Jedenfalls war da heute Morgen
ein super spannender Talk
von so einem weirden Ufologen.
Ein Typ, der
meint, er hatte Kontakte ins Pentagon
und so und wüsste, dass es Aliens gibt und kennt auch alles. Und es war so entspannend für diesen offensichtlichen Nonsens, Dr. Greer oder so heißt er, der hat auch ein paar Dokumentationen rausgebracht, die, glaube ich, einfach interessant sind zu gucken. Weil er einfach behauptet, dass die Menschheit schon seit Jahren Kontakt zu Aliens hat und so was. Und er hat auch Beweise bis hin zu den Obersten Regen und Classified Information und so weiter. Und es war so spannend, weil es einfach ein Q&A. Und da kam ich gerade darauf wegen Tentakeln, weil dann einfach so Leute die ganze Zeit Fragen gestellt haben mit Und gibt es denn Ex-Menschen? Gibt es denn, wie muss man sich Aliens vorstellen? Haben die dann teilweise Tentakeln? Und seine Grenze von er antwortet auf Fragen ernst bis hin zu er stapelt die als Nonsens ab, war so schmal, weil dann war es sowas wie, er war die ganze Zeit relativ seriös so. Das erste Mal dachte ich mir, okay, vielleicht ist er doch ernst zu nehmen, als dann gefragt wurde, sind denn die Nazis slash andere Leute auf der Rückseite des Mondes?
Das stimmt doch, dass da Leute sind. Er hat gesagt, nein. Also das war fader weggelacht. Dann war aber direkt die nächste Frage, gibt es Echsenmenschen? Und er hat ernst darauf geantwortet, ja natürlich gibt es Echsenmenschen. Wo ich dann dachte, hä? Weil, also weil irgendwie in meinem Kopf war es immer so, wenn du Verschwörungstheoretiker bist, dann aber auch the full package. Dann glaubst du auch, dass die Erde flach ist, Corona eine Lüge ist und so weiter, und die Mondlandung nie existiert ist. Aber bei ihm war es so ganz klar, für was er ist und was er aber nicht glaubt. Echsenmenschen, total yes, hinter dem Mond, der Mond ist völlig egal. Der Mond spielt in seiner, als Mond wäre ich auch sauer, dass man in seiner Verschwörungstheorie-Zirkus-Belt keine Rolle spielt, keine Rolle bekommen hat. Das ist dann trotzdem noch Fantasy, das ist merkwürdig, wo die die Grenze ziehen. Ich würde die auch gerne einfach mal zusammentun, so Leute, die dann vielleicht so überlappen, ein Verschwörungstheorie glaubt, Mondlandung und dann noch ein paar andere Sachen und der andere auch ein paar andere Sachen und Mondlandung und die mal zusammentun, die sich bei allem Themen total gut verstehen und beim anderen denken, was für ein bescheuertes Arsch auf Wachsinn glaubst du denn eigentlich mit der Mudflat, dass einmal alles überflutet wurde. Dr. Greer kann ja jetzt nicht denken, dass die Erde eine Scheibe ist, denke ich mir. Weil er glaubt ja auch an Satelliten und sowas. Vielleicht glauben er nicht an Satelliten, doch. Doch, es kommt darauf an, das ist ja das Ding so, es gibt ja keine einheitliche Idee, sondern ganz viele, die sich vermischen und die ja dann zusammenkommen und sagen, das ist ja das Spannende bei diesen Verschwörungstheoretikern, ich habe ja bei dieser 9-11-Sache recherchiert und da hast du halt dann so Versammlungen und die halten dann Vorträge und die haben völlig unterschiedliche Meinungen, was passiert ist. Der eine sagt, Bombe ist explodiert, der andere sagt, Raketen sind reingeflogen, aber die kommen trotzdem miteinander klar, obwohl die sich genauso widersprechen, wie ich einem von denen widersprechen würde. Aber die kommen da irgendwie mit klar und sagen, ja. Ja, weil sie sich halt einig sind, dass es nicht so ist, wie alle anderen glauben. Ja, genau, das reicht. Aber dann dachte ich mir auch beim Hören so, wie gern ich das glauben würde, alles. Wie gern ich glauben würde, dass es Aliens gibt, die mit uns in Kontakt sind. Aber macht es das nicht noch langweiliger, weil du dann kannst ja nicht mehr Alien gucken und du denkst, ah, ist das wirklich so, woher wissen die das? Und so, du kannst es ja nicht als Fantasy-Spaß genießen. Weil dann hat er auch sowas gesagt. Dann war so, ja, was ist gerade irgendwie die neuste Entwicklung und sowas und dann meinte er, ja, erst vor wenigen Monaten hat die Raumsonde Cassini, die wir so durch unser Sonnensystem schicken, kam an einer riesen Alien-Konstruktion am Saturn vorbei. Ein so ein 13 Kilometer großes Raumschiff, deren Bauweise und so wäre uns auch schon bekannt. Wir wüssten schon, dass es dieses Alien-Spezies gibt. Und ich dachte die ganze Zeit, ich bin mit so einem
breiten Grinsen rumgelaufen mit diesem
Kopfhörer an den Ohren, weil ich dachte, wie
cool ist das denn, wenn man das glaubt.
Und dann habe ich mich auch geärgert,
dass ich es nicht glaube. Und dann habe
ich mich auch gefragt, reicht es
einfach zu behaupten, dass man
Leute kennt in hohen Positionen?
Oder ist da dann was dran?
Also,
verarschen die den vielleicht?
War das vielleicht ein sehr
Die Leute gekennend in hohen Positionen? Oder ist da dann was dran? Also, verarschen die den vielleicht?
elaborierter Prank von NASA-Mitarbeitern,
die über lange, lange Zeit
jemanden pranken, um ihn lächerlich
zu machen? Weil der Typ ist ja nicht
bescheuert, der hat wahrscheinlich wenig einen Doktor
in Medizin,
glaube ich. Und dann hat er
das irgendwann beiseitegelegt und gesagt, komm, ich konzentriere mich auf diese UFOs da im Himmel, was ist da eigentlich los? Und der kann sich auch gut ausdrücken und sowas. Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, dass jemand so viel Zeit in seinem Lebensfeld verbringt, um Leute zu verarschen. Ich glaube, der glaubt davon einen Teil. Aber dann frage ich mich, wer gibt ihm denn Informationen, falsche Informationen? Ja, ist schwierig. Vielleicht war es auch einfach nur ein Alien-Fan, der irgendwann dachte, ich habe mein ganzes Leben verschwendet mit Alien Science Fiction. Klick, nee, ich bin Alien-Forscher, ich habe die halt erforscht. Ich habe auch mal einen Vortrag gesehen von so Leuten, die nicht an Dinosauriern glauben und die dann meinten, ja, früher vor der Sintflut, die ja dann, vor der Sintflut gab. Funfakt, nicht alle, die Dinosaurier leugnen, glauben auch an die Sintflut.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Wild durchgemischt. Und die meinten, ja, vor der Sintflut gab es viel mehr CO2 auf der Erde.
Und deswegen kann es auch sein, dass die Dinosaurier, die es da vorher noch gab, vor der Sintflut, kann gut sein, dass die beim Ausatmen,
da musste er selber so ein bisschen innehalten, dass die beim Ausatmen Feuer gespuckt haben. Und was sich dann natürlich in verschiedenen Kulturen als Drachen niederschlägt. Und da war schon im Raum so eine Stimmung so, wirklich, wir holen jetzt noch Drachen rein? Ich meine, wir sind okay, wir sind sehr bibeltreue Fundamentalisten, Christen, aber jetzt noch Drachen? Engel, klar, easy, kein Ding, Engel, easy, Teufel, Dämon, cool, aber jetzt noch Drachen? Gab es in der Bibel nicht auch Drachen oder zumindest so in der Bibel, so Titanen oder so ein Scheiß? Nein, bin ich gerade auch im Franchise. Nee, nur so komische Nephilim-Riesendinger, die dann weg mussten.
Also finde ich auch geil, dass die Bibel ja auch sagt, da hat Gott sich einfach vertan.
Der hatte ja diese Riesen geschaffen und dachte, oh scheiße, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr mit der Lore.
Und mit wem dürfen die sich jetzt fortpflanzen?
Und ach, weißt du was, fuck it, einfach alles auswählen, delete, wir machen einmal Sinnflut.
Command Z. Command Z,
einmal Sintflut und dann Noah
bleibt da und alle Fische.
Und dann
haben wir wenigstens dieses dumme Problem mit
diesen Riesen nicht mehr.
Das ist auch keine
Riesenprobleme.
Wo kurz ein Godzilla
Bibel-Crossover stattgefunden hat,
um was nicht gut funktioniert. Ja, ich meine, wie viele Staffeln sind die alte, das alte Testament, es sind so 18 Staffeln, wo du immer wieder guckst, wie kannst du die letzte Staffel toppen, was kannst du noch einführen, was kommt, jetzt ist so ein bisschen Vampire Diaries mässig, wo halt irgendwann dann halt wirklich dir die Bösewichte ausgehen und dann halt der Teufel einfach auftaucht und du sagst, Leute, euch ist schon klar, wenn wir jetzt in Staffel 8 den Teufel machen, was soll in Staffel 9 noch passieren? Die dann irgendwann in Staffel 4 schon den Gott hatten, den Gott, wo man sagt, ich bin mal gespannt, was jetzt passiert. Ja, es ist schwierig. Ich will nicht gerne wissen, was dann passiert. Und irgendwann brauchst du halt die Sintfluten und sagst, komm, hau ab, haut ab jetzt hier, haut ab nochmal, aber verrannt. Aber das war wirklich was, ich weiß nicht, ich bin noch, ich bin zwiegespalten bei der App. Du willst einen Credit, du willst, dass der Kurs Stefan Tietze erstmal steht, wenn man die App aufmacht. Am liebsten hätte ich wirklich gerne, dass die App das Podcast-Ufo heisst, aber gut, der ist irgendwie abgefahren. Ich finde es nur irgendwie, also das hat mir ein bisschen zu denken gegeben, weil ich fand die App eigentlich ganz cool, Wie sie gerade genutzt ist, für mich nicht so geil, aber ich glaube, die Perspektiven sind geil und auch was für uns Podcaster da möglich ist, perspektivisch, glaube ich, ist ziemlich cool.
Aber wenn da heute einfach so Leute ihren Nonsens verbreiten können.
Weil dieser Alien-Forscher, der tut ja gerade noch niemandem weh.
Aber dann war es auch wieder der Typ, der die Interviewte auf diese Bühne geholt hat.
Der hat dann während live einen Anruf bekommen mit einer Morddrohung. Um Gottes Willen. Das hat man nicht gehört. Aber von wem? Von weltlichen Kräften oder außerweltlichen? Also meines Aliens haben seine Nummer gewählt. Wäre naheliegend, dass er sagt, bevor die die ganzen Geheimnisse ausplaudern. Nee, ich glaube, innermenschlich. Hat er einen Anruf bekommen, der war dann kurz weg und kam dann wieder mit blasser Stimme. Ich habe gerade eine Morddrohung bekommen und dann mannte dieser Ufologe, ja das wäre normal, das würde ihm häufiger passieren. Das sind Leute, die nicht wollen, dass... Ja, es war wirklich spannend. Oder habe ich irgendwie so eine, war das eine fiktionale Inszenierung? Das war ein Impotheater. Aber das kann natürlich auch einfach behauptet sein, um so ein bisschen das ein bisschen wichtiger darzustellen. Ich meine, es kann natürlich auch wirklich sein. Der hat ja sehr gut gespielt. Ja, wirklich? Aber wer macht denn wirklich Morddrohungen von Leuten, die sagen, es gibt Aliens? Nee, es gibt keine Aliens. Die sagen noch, es gibt Aliens. Die sagen, es gibt Aliens. Wer droht Menschen, die an Aliens glauben? Ja. Aber auch umgekehrt weird. Wer droht Menschen, die nicht an Ali? Also keiner der beiden Parteien sollte die anderen töten wollen. Du bist der Hochlord Morgoth, der 20.000 Lichtjahre durchs Universum gereist ist. Und du leugtest mich. Und die Leute sagen, den gibt's nicht. Dann klingel ich aber auch mal durch. 0800 Hitze und sag, Entschuldigung, wenn sie nicht mehr aufhören, wenn Sie glauben, bringe ich Sie um.
Nee, aber es war ein Mensch, der gesagt hat,
hör auf, diesen Mist zu erzählen und halt dich von diesem Ufologen fern.
Der Ufologe, den habe ich dann gegoogelt
und habe dann auch ein paar Videos bei YouTube bei ihm geguckt,
der glaubt aber an Corona. Ach gut,
das ist auch gut. Ja, fand ich auch beruhigend.
Die würfeln das aus. Ich glaube, du würfelst
das wirklich mal aus. Aber ich war so gespannt darauf, was er zu Corona sagt. Weil dann war das erste Video, was wir angesagt wurde, direkt Covid-19, wo ich dachte, ja, echt gespannt, was jetzt Dr. Greer, ich glaube an Aliens und dem Saturn ist ein riesen, 30 Kilometer großes Raumschiff und Echsenmenschen gibt es aber hinter dem Mond, da bist du bescheuert. Was der zu Corona sagt, fand ich wirklich interessant. Da ist ja auch schwer, dass so eine Sache nicht dein komplettes Leben bestimmt. Wenn du wirklich denkst, da hängen die am Saturn rum und kommen gleich zur Invasion. Was machen die? Sich dann irgendwie noch über Biber zu informieren, eine schöne Biber-Doku auf Arte zu geben, ist schwierig. Weil du denkst, das ist doch eigentlich egal. Aber er hat auch eine ganz strenge, ich habe mich sehr mit dem Ausnahmsen heute, er hat eine sehr interessante Ansicht. Er sagt, Aliens sind nicht feindselig, sonst wären wir schon lange tot. Und zwar hätten die uns dann ausgelöscht, als wir die erste Atombombe gezündet hätten. Weil dann sind wir als Zivilisation offensichtlich zu gefährlich und dann werden wir weggeswiped von den Aliens. Da das aber nicht passiert ist, sagt er, sind die nicht feindselig. Nur schüchtern. Die sind halt gerade beim Satuern und gucken halt gerade und wollen uns zum Promo einladen. Was ist das Schlimmste, das passieren könnte? Na, sprich dir einfach mal an. Geh doch einfach mal hin. Die könnten uns sagen, dass unsere Tentakel wo geht sind. Ach Quatsch, ja und dann sagst du nicht, nein, dann sagst du, ihr habt nur zwei Tentakel, das ist Bullshit. Das ist doch egal, was sie sagen über dich. Hey! Wir tragen Hosen mit Taschen über unseren Taubtaschen. Ja, aber ich weiss, wir haben einige körperliche Makel. Schatz, wir haben zwei Münder. Ja, ich weiss. Mit sehr vielen Zähnen. Ich habe einfach Angst, dass uns wie auf Beta 13 diese Todesschreie entgegenkommt. Ich möchte nicht mehr in den Spiegel gucken und denken, ich bin wirklich gruselig. Ich sehe aus wie von HR Giga gezeichnet. Flip, wir sind jetzt durch die ganze Galaxie gereist, nur um hierher zu kommen. Wir werden jetzt nicht fünf Kilometer vor der Erde umdrehen. Nein, ich sage mir mal zu, Frau Granta. Wir sind nicht schön. Wir sind keine schönen Lebewesen. Das hat der Wettbewerb auf Oregon 19. Ja, ich erinnere mich. Objektiv gesagt. Hässlichste Spezies. Gehst du jetzt da hin oder nicht? Sonst fahren wir wieder. Trau dich doch mal. Hm? Na komm schon! Okay, ich ziehe mir noch kurz was Schönes über. Es kann einfach sein, dass es das braucht. Vielleicht sind die einfach sehr, sehr schüchtern und brauchen sehr, sehr lange, bis sie sich trauen, uns anzusprechern. Du! Dass die so mit Überlichtgeschwindigkeit hergekommen sind und dann da beim Saturn, da haben sie sich entschieden zu sein. Was ist denn das so spannend? Der hat Ringe. Cool. Als ob die nicht irgendwie andere Planeten schon gefunden haben, die Ringe haben. Die haben halt einfach so ein bisschen falsch abgewogen. Es muss hier irgendwo sein. Es muss hier sein. Es muss hier irgendwo sein. Vielleicht denken die, der Planet wäre viel grösser. Aber die Erde ist halt einfach relativ klein und die fragen sich die ganze Zeit, wo wir sind. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber auch spannend. Aber der kann doch jetzt nicht mehr sterben, oder? Leute, ich bleib da dran. Der Professor kann doch jetzt nicht mehr sterben. Nee, mach keinen Professor aus ihm, einen Doktor. Doktor, der muss doch wissen, bald ist der Kontakt und der kann doch jetzt nicht mehr sagen, ich hau jetzt ab. Ja, vor allem, wenn dann mal Kontakt hergestellt wird und das für alle der coolste Tag ist, fliegt er einfach als Lügner auf, obwohl das sein Tag sein sollte. Ja. Oder er hatte all along recht, wir sind die ganze Zeit schon in Kontakt mit Außerirdischen. Wir halten die Augen offen, falls ihr außerirdisch seid und sagt, hey, ihr wollt Kontakt aufnehmen. Tut das, schreibt uns eine Mail, wir sind gerne für den Erstkontakt zu haben, überhaupt kein Problem. Und guckt mal mehr in den Himmel. Guckt mal einfach in den Himmel, ob da was ist. Einfach mal so. Ja, guckt einfach mal raus, Vielleicht seht ihr was. Zeigt mit dem Finger drauf und sagt, na, vielleicht?
Weil wir sind ja jetzt alle zu Hause die ganze Zeit.
Lass mal ein bisschen mehr einfach auf den Himmel achten.
Penso auf.
Oder zu, aber auch einfach rausgucken.
Habt eine schöne Woche. Viel Spaß.
Wir sind das Podcast-UFO.
Und wir heben es ab.
Zu Wallsboro Production.